my name is mir kommen liegen zuschauer
ihr seht es bereits im titel wir machen
wollte die versuche nicht weit zu sagen
challenge luca hammer idee scheiterte
challenge war eigentlich schon vor einem
halben jahr hier in deutschland am start
und jeder hat dazu irgendwie ein video
gemacht und jedes amt nails auch
irgendwie gleich aus kreativ aber ich
würde sagen fragt damit der erste
compilation auf die wir heute reagieren
werden ja meist ein
was also ich versuche das ganze erstmal
nachzustellen und zwar ich ja auch ein
15 stück das heißt ich muss jetzt
einfach mal hoch und machen wir
allerdings direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten video und zwar hat er ein
basketball und er haut ihn werde jedoch
nicht rein
aber auch den trick statt stelle ich
natürlich nach und zwar seht ihr schon
da vorne einen mülleimer ich habe hier
ein basketball das heißt ich werde den
jetzt einfach mal da rein
das war gar nicht mal so knapp dass hier
ist das nächste video ich glaube eher
nicht dass ich sie hier raus gegangen
ach ja mir auch wieder ein basketball
trick schott video
ich weiß nicht wo der wirt von der ganz
hinten der ball geht hinter den korb das
hier ist das nächste video das ist
baseball und ich habe keine ahnung was
hier
im moment heraus
hey
also da er das war's nur hier wieder den
basketball und der landet auch daneben
aber jetzt ja klar ich kann das auch bei
glaubt ihr was drin
das hier ist das nächste video es ist
ein golfer der haut den golfball
komplett weit weg ja das wäre das ist ja
schon klar der trifft direkt das loch
das ist also etwas das man geht und dass
das kann nicht sein das kann nicht sein
ja wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich klar
logisch ja klar wer kennt es nicht der
ball rollt einfach mal so über den
ganzen platz in dieses loch rein das ist
das nächste video ich glaube dass es ein
papierflieger den er da fliegen lässt ja
genau da unten fliegt papierflieger wo
sitzen sie denn überhaupt diese zehn wie
auch wegen dem schuldach drauf da unten
fliegt auf jeden fall die ganze zeit
immer weiter beide fliegen die ganze
zeit immer weiter ich habe keine ahnung
welchen ich mich gerade konzentrieren
sondern ich gesagt ich glaube es geht um
diesen weißen hier unten und er dreht
sind noch eine runde alltag wie weit
oben sitzen die denn jetzt müssen wir
aber mal langsam irgendwo rein fliegen
und er fliegt
[Musik]
das sollte er de train to say was dir
ist es wieder ein basketball video er
wirft den ball hinter den links er auch
dann hinterher sie die ganze zeit herum
und geht
da war doch mal das logo
90 prozent der videos sind einfach nur
ich wie ich klatschen durch manchmal
laufe ich versuch's mal wieder nach zu
stellen hat nicht so ganz geklappt dass
jetzt das nächste video wieder ein
basketball video er schmeißt rückwärts
den weil ja kann ich den schrei
vielleicht noch mal hören
[Applaus]
hier wieder ein golf video houten ball
komplett weg den golfball ich habe keine
ahnung ob deren genauen namen hat ein
golfball ich kann mich mit gold 0 kommen
noch aus der ball rollt
ganz kurz ist das immer noch gilt dieser
schlag jetzt als widget beim golf oder
muss er den jetzt noch mal machen
das interessiert mich eigentlich 0,0
dass jetzt das nächste video ist es
wieder ein basketball video ich habe
keine auch mein gott ja genau
bisher ich bin froh wenn ich eine pizza
im ofen machen kann und der hat andere
talente allerdings machen wir hier
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten video das
sind keine videos jetzt was macht er da
überhaupt streichelt er seinen
rückspiegel oder war
okay das war schon ein bisschen
einfach das komplette eis von dem
spiegel in einem stück abgenommen die
videos hier haben keinen ton
beziehungsweise gehört halt einfach
hintergrundmusik von mir hier
eingeblendet weil das videos sind de auf
irgendwelchen compilation website
hochgeladen
alter
das ist
putzen auf einem ganz ganz hohem niveau
hier reinigt jemand eine wand mit einem
hochdruckreiniger dabei solche videos
kenne ich schon also ich habe selber
meine terrasse oben auch mit einem
hochdruckreiniger mal sauber gemacht und
das sieht so krass aus also ich habe bei
mir fast so pvc holz das ist so
pvc holz und man denkt halt wirklich
dass dieses holz sauber ist und dann
geht man aber trotzdem noch mit dem
hochdruckreiniger darüber und es wird so
komplett clean
also ich weiß nämlich davon ein video
habe allerdings machen wir hier direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten video
ich habe keine ahnung was der da gerade
in der hand hat was das sein soll er
drückte auf irgendwelche knöpfe darauf
das sieht aus wie ein überdimensionales
taschen voll okay das ist so machen
allerdings nicht weiter mit dem nächsten
video und zwar ist das hier einfach ein
gekochtes ei und her macht das auf und
das ei ist offen
ja geil keine ahnung was daran gerade
zum wow sagen sein sollte aber das hier
ist das nächste video das ist ein
ich glaube da mein gott das ist raus ach
so ich dachte dass der wasser das hier
ist ein zugefrorener see teich fluss
keine ahnung was mein gott
alter das alter was das sieht aus wie
sowieso kristalle oder sowas bot guckt
euch das hier mal ein alter machen war
allerdings direkt weiter mit diesem
video hier uns war es dass hier ein
flammenwerfer in slow motion lokal
krasse sieht auf jeden fall auch herr o
bei gott
wie weit
kann denn alter mal ganz kurz zu beginn
sah das ganze so aus da dachte ich schon
alter.de krank es ist also egal wie weit
kann das ding denn feuersteinen machen
wir allerdings weiter mit dieser person
hier und zwar schmeißt er seinen
fallschirm oder seine rohre okay das
sind cool aus er hat seinen drachen auf
jeden fall einfach in die luft
geschmissen jetzt einfach weg nie hat
jemand ein messer und lässt
alter ist das so schaaf was beim
einmessen wird er das messer kaputt
gehen als das gemüse hier hat jemand
eine zeichnung gemacht und mit feuer
macht er das ganze jetzt weg ich habe
keine ahnung wie das funktioniert
vielleicht ist es irgendwie sah er hat
das bestimmt mit rauch gezeichnet hier
das ist ein pinsel in einer farbe oder
nee das ist das muss ja viel größer sein
das sieht aus wie so ein schneeschieber
gerät was da irgendwie durch seine
farbtons gemacht wird weiter sieht also
die muster sind was das ist dass matt
hier fertigt jemand eine schüssel an
glaube ich und verziert diese schüssel
ich find's ok ich also was leute
teilweise für künstlerische
eigenschaften haben das mega krass aber
hier der abstand ist ja überhaupt nicht
wie der abstand zum audi hat jemand
wieder einen pinsel in der hand und
zeichnet und entsteht so etwas erinnert
mich immer an meine zeit noch in der
schule aber halt nicht so die zeit in
der schule wo man halt kunst irgendwie
dann gymnasium oberstufe hat und dann
kunst analysen geschrieben hat sondern
wo man wirklich selber gezeichnet hat so
richtig und dann so mit pin sind so
einer grundschule und so eine ahnung was
das hier ist aber da werden irgendwie
scheiben von abgeschnitten
ich habe keine ahnung was das ist oder
ob das irgendwie sogar animiert ist aber
hier ist eine bahn in den alpen die
fährt da drum rum und jetzt kommt eine
band das doch also das ist dass es
definitiv schneller gemacht worden sieht
man auch hier an den bäumen ziemlich
klar haben jetzt allerdings auch schon
zum letzten video hier und zwar befindet
sich hier jemand auf einem ball und
macht auch in dicker
was das
klick unter dem video auf abonnieren
oder eure ärmel rutschen runter beim
händewaschen xd
[Musik]